[Music]
call your parents to drag out those toy
chests and get ready to explain years of
amazing nonsense loyalty and normal
friends because Transformers rise of the
Beast just release its first trailer and
the internet is going wild inspired by
the Beast Wars series in the 1990s rise
of the Beast continues the franchises
much needed transformation which
successfully began with the
well-received soft reboot bumblebee
longtime Transformers voice actor Peter
Cullen leads as Optimus Prime opposite
Cullen is Hellboy star Ron Perlman as
Optimus primor the leader of the new
animal-like robots called maximors Pete
Davidson Liza koshy and Futurama's John
DiMaggio also stars as Autobots Mirage
RC and Stratosphere respectively the
film's primary villain seems to be the
Terracon leader Scourge played by Game
of Throne star Peter Dinklage Anthony
Ramos and Dominic Fishback will also
appear a central human characters with a
stats cast and a strong visual style
Transformers fans are having trouble War
containing their assignments for the new
film even before the trailer for
Transformers rise of the Beast dropped
fans took to the Transformers subreddit
to share their anticipation one
concerned redditor shared the
apprehension stating this is even going
to make or ruin my year Moment of Truth
Paramount the current top voted comments
in the entire thread was also written a
few hours before the trailer was
released saying can't wait to discuss
transforming Gorillas with y'all four
years in the waiting and Delta leaders
person must have been very pleased of
how much emphasis Optimus Prime will
received in the first trailer overall
though the trailer was met by the sir
Reddit with near Universal praise an
excited fan praise primor's design and
the use of mirage's powers while another
commenter wanted to accelerate the clock
to get to the release date it seems the
momentum of the trailer has even
inspired fans of all ages to rush to the
toy aisle one user said my bank account
is not prepared for how much merge this
movie will generate another fan
responded to this comment saying right I
I was planning to pass but that leaked
air razor figure is giving me second
thoughts Lord help me if Primal looks
good
[Music]
aside from Optimus primor Mirage seems
to be the clear standout as a police fan
ghost about 2 writing Mirage looks
pretty cool in the teaser they released
his transformation was really smooth and
even in that small clip the way he moves
gives him a lot of Personality like
2018's Bumblebee Transformers rise of
the Beast reworked the Bots character
models to resemble their cartoon toy
counterparts more closely
as a user puts it they simplify the
designs and leaned into colors enough
that now I can see two Bots fighting on
screen and actually be able to make out
who's who and there's not just a bunch
of moving metal plates banging into each
other another fan agreed with this
sentiment saying the maximoles look both
faithful and amazing there were some
however who had issues with minor
aspects of the trailer a concerned
redditor said just watched it Primo's
voice will take a bit of getting used to
but I can get behind it
excuse me
another fan agreed with the comments
about primal's voice however they
appreciated the teaser trailer a
different user felt Optimus Prime's look
wasn't as faithful to the original
series writing did anyone notice
optimus's new design feels like it isn't
as G1 compared to the Bumblebee film but
might be wrong overall the mood is
certainly hopeful in the Transformers
fanbase as they anxiously awaits the
release of Rise of the beasts
[Music]